[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz and
co-hosting today with my good friend
ands personality George camel and we are
here to take your calls America it is a
free call anywhere in the country which
it's been a free call for a long time
George when are we going to start
charging Rachel we kind of's killing us
that's like a 2000 if you remember
having to pay for longdistance calls
when that was a thing calls but it is a
it is a call any call in the country at
88255 at 225 and we will answer your
money questions relationship questions
questions about work we are here to talk
to you so first up we have Porsche in
Houston Texas hey Porsha welcome to the
show hi hi Rachel hi George love your
book breaking fre joke oh thank you it's
a good shout out how can we help you
today yes
so I just graduated from school um in
December and I feel like I'm late with
everything so I have of course debt and
I'm just trying to find like the proper
time to
purchase my house the when I did the
numbers when I worked the numbers it
appears that based on my income I will
be able to pay my debt off in about two
years so my car I only have like two
major debts which is my car and my
student loans my car is
14.5 K remaining and so I'm paying it
off I'll be done paying that off in
April um yay
excited that's great and my student loan
is
134,000 what's your degree done it's um
my MERS in finance and Investment
Management okay and do you have a job
did you get one out of
school yes I did how much are you
making uh 166,000 a year good for you
Porsha that's
awesome thank you so what's your
question
today so when I pay this off because I'm
all for I'm disgusted by thatt like I am
not interested so I'm pass I cut up my
credit cards I'm done I just want to
know I don't have any kids yet and so I
and and I am getting married too soon oh
congratulations I just want to know like
thank you so much I just want to know
like when is will it be a proper time to
pay for a house or do I rent like George
I've heard you speak on like you know
don't get caught up in the whole where
my kids are going to be you know where
you know thinking family the big yard
the whole nine and a townhouse renting a
town home can be so I'm thinking in my
situation is that the direction because
I'm thinking about my age how old are
you I'm 35 I'm 35 oh my goodness ancient
throw in the towel pack it up porsa it's
it's over it's over you know life is
Rachel hit her prime about 24 and it's
been downhill
since but no pora we're kidding you have
so much time you're doing great but I
know compared to your peers you're
seeing people in their 20s they're like
well they I should own a home by now but
also you had a different journey and you
got a masters and you got further
education and you had debt and so that's
okay that you know you're delayed with
this dream but don't do what most people
do which is go buy a house while you
have a giant pile of debt why you're
trying to invest why you're trying to do
everything else in life yeah when are
you getting married
Porsche I'm getting married this Summer
this summer okay that's great and what's
kind of what's his status like do you
guys know where you want to live do you
um yeah are you guys on the same page
with all of
that yeah well he has no debt he's never
financed the car he's awesome that's
great I like this guy already he sounds
like a winner so what were you do you
know what his income is or are you not
there yet in the relationship I hope so
they're engaged you never know we've
been together for years so um his he
yeah he he makes 22,000 a year okay so
you'll have an household income of over
200k this summer yeah which is going to
speed up your debt payoff
process yeah if he's the man I hope I
hope he is which is we're going to clean
up our mess
now yeah that's right yeah he he ENC
he's very encouraging so let's play this
out by April the student loans are gone
you get married in the summer you're
attacking the student loans and when do
you think it'll be paid off with all
that factored in with his
income
uh and maybe his savings who knows he
may come in with 100 Grand in savings
and be able to wipe out your
debt true um well I when I did the
masth I I know I could pay my car off
quick like in three months I'm already
on track with that um so I I'm paying
like 2500 every two weeks to pay that
off five grand a month you're throwing a
debt yes okay and now the student loans
it does well the student loss is
134,000 and I think it'll take me about
two years because I decided to live on
just maybe 30% of my
income to pay it off yeah and that's
great and and Porsha and I honestly with
you guys getting married combining
incomes and like George said him
bringing any anything into the into the
marriage you guys together you'll pay it
off faster I really do believe that so
whether it is you guys combining and
being on the same team or even just you
I mean I just I can already tell from
this call and the tone of your voice I'm
like you're going to do this quickly and
probably faster than you even realize so
yeah I think once you're out of debt I
would build up a strong emergency fund
of 3 to six months of expenses and then
by that point I mean yeah you and him I
think you guys really look and say okay
you know where where do we want to live
what is this one what do we want to you
know where what part of Houston do we
want to be do we want to do a town home
since we don't have kids right now do we
and can we maybe afford something more
and that's what we choose to step into
so I think it's totally up to you guys I
think I would stick with that formula
though of your of your payment being no
more than 25% of your take-home pay I
think that's where it gets a lot of
people and and really you know you guys
together look but I think it's going to
be sooner than what you think Porsche
and I think that's the best next step
for you all is to save up that down
payment and if um does he own a home
now no okay no that's great yeah yeah so
I mean for a year or two and get that
down payment saved up and that may be
four years from now you guys get into
this house but you're going to do it
with so much peace and patience and
Equity that it's going to be a blessing
instead of a burden yeah that's right
well
Porche yeah go go ahead family can stess
I was going to say I appreciate that
because family can we ain't G to get a
house I know you got to turn that volume
down they don't pay your bills por sure
that's the problem if they did that'd be
great said great you go get me a house
then if you want me to have one so bad
right right so that's the problem is
avoiding all the pressure that's the
hardest part of this whole financial
mess yes and I think people you know
they say that from one element of like
establishing roots and having your place
but also from a financial standpoint of
yeah once you get in You're Building
equity and it's you know it's good for
your overall Financial picture but
Porsche you guys are going to be fine
you're going to be fine you're going to
get a house when it's best for you guys
you're going to both be investing you
make insane money you make great money
over 200 and so you guys will start
investing consistently you're going to
build you know I really think a great a
great financial life together and the
fact that he has such great common sense
with money and already such great money
habits from what you've said uh I think
you're going to you're going to do great
so here George and I as your friends
patience you're fine you're good without
buying a house pay off that debt get a
good emergency fund down payment and
you're good to go this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls and up next we have
Seth in New Orleans hey Seth welcome to
the
show hey thanks for having me absolutely
how can we
help well I mean not to be too long with
it but 2018 uh rolled around and uh Dave
came out to church nearby my house and
uh went and listened to him talk and you
know I've been broke and working hard
and uh decided that I'd follow him and
be working hard not broke and uh over
the last couple years I've worked real
hard and put a lot of you know seeds in
the ground and this Hall the day had
some of my family over and I have new
property and some some new space and
they wound up um you know asking about
the mortgage we're working on some land
and ask about mortgage and you know I
just kind of said I don't have mortgage
on the property and then uh you know one
thing came to another and we it came out
that we had a lot more money than my
family had ever thought you could have
and it it's caused quite a bit of quite
a bit of a hum dig around the the the
family so so have they asked you for
money or they just upset and envious
that you don't have debt and you're not
strapped with
payments oh yeah no all yes sir all of
it sir so they straight up said hey you
doing pretty well boy aren't you you got
any of that money laying around for us
like was it joking or was it pretty
serious no I mean we went out for we
have mess of kids you know and so we
went out one night for something and ice
cream was there and I was like you know
you told my kids grab ice cream whatever
kids grab ice cream I end up getting ice
cream forever which isn't a big thing
anymore and uh you know like it must be
nice you know and then the next night
they were saying you know we're going
out to dinner and my wife was oh only
went to dinner family over so like oh
just the two of us will go out and oh
you got us you can go too this no I do
not I do not have you so there's there's
assumptions and entitlement now of like
well he'll cover it cuz he's doing
pretty well so he should cover it and is
this your direct parents like who who
Who's involved here everyone yeah know
everyone asked throughout the course of
the two weeks after that you know they
found out about Aunts Uncles cousins
yes sir all the phone calls and
everything goodness gracious it's like
you won the lot but it's taking you how
much money do you guys actually
have a lot uh I mean I don't know a lot
for everyone is uh a lot for what I
thought we uh you know my wife and I
picked up we stopped whining and started
working which is kind of our joke to us
and uh I don't know we put some things
together and right now I think on we did
our net worth at the end beginning year
and it was about right under four four
million oh my goodness great that is
amazing how old are you too yeah I'm 37
we're 37 so that's incredible and this
is mostly your family not
hers no her her family doesn't know and
and I mean you're like they're not going
to we're not telling anybody else after
this
debacle oh yeah they're good though
they're all square they're not they're
not my side be like oh good for you are
is your family local Seth do you guys
have like day-to-day interaction with
them not so much right now but yes ma'am
yes ma'am okay but they're local and you
guys usually would like kind of do life
together you you do dinners together
like they're a part of your rhythm in
life yes
okay H Seth it's it's about to get
uncomfortable how do how do you feel are
you like pissed about it or are you
confused with it or you do you feel bad
like what what's your overall emotion
well I was I was upset the first night
so I end up calling everyone together
the next night and I was like listen my
responsibility is take care of my wife
and my kids and I'm going to do that and
I I I told them I would put them through
FPU you know and I wrote a list of all
the books I read I mean I picked up
majority all books and uh the library is
free you know and so I was like I tell
you all the books right you can read
those you know I'll tell you what I did
they're not interested in learning that
it's pretty bold Seth the next night I
was expecting us to have like a
conversation about saying a boundary you
just did it the day after so then how do
they respond to that they asked for for
you to pay for their dinner I think yeah
yeah pretty much you know they're like
well if you don't have it or you don't
want to share you know and it's it was
just a lot of guilt and so I've been
wrestling with it for a couple months
now and I was listen to Y show and I was
like you know what I should probably
just call and say hey y'all I mean you
guys have money I don't have a lot of
people in my life that have money so you
know have new friends I guess but it's
hard to say you know to your brother
looking at you he's like hey you know
you got $10,000 for a business like I
don't have $10,000 for your business I'm
sorry that's not what I have this is not
bank ofth but I'm not there that's right
you've approached this with a lot of
tact and wisdom and maturity which I
applaud you for and the fact that you're
even willing to have the hard
conversation tells me that there is hope
here but it may take a few of these
conversations and enough times to where
they get the hint and you know what that
might hurt these relationships these
people may not want to hang out and go
to dinner because they have some own
resentment that they you know some
poison they've been been drinking yeah
and so I don't want that to be a
reflection on you and it's going to be
painful in some of these situations but
you have to do what's right for your
family and you can't let this generosity
turn into requirement because that takes
all of the joy out of it yeah and SE and
you and just so you know and I know you
probably know this but just to say it
out loud like you've done nothing wrong
right and I feel like what can happen is
they can pin you in a corner where you
feel like suddenly if you don't do
something you're doing something wrong
because yeah do you have the means yeah
you guys do but you're an adult and you
get to decide what you do just like what
you told them what you your
responsibility is to you and your family
and what you do beyond that is up to you
but by you existing with this money that
is not a wrong you're not you're not in
the wrong and I feel like sometimes you
can feel like oh my gosh I've done i'
I'm the one that's done something that's
not good or not okay and so just
remember that that you haven't done you
haven't done anything wrong and the
truth is George said it but it probably
sadly will create a divide and I wish
that wasn't the case but I feel like
they've proven themselves after you set
a pretty strong boundary and were very
honest and clear they chose to overstep
that boundary and asked you to pay for
dinner that night so I think you have to
have a realization too and and you
probably already have but you and your
wife stick together as a team and just
realize oh my gosh sadly they they don't
have the maturity to handle this part of
your life that that you brought them
into right by sharing this information
um and that's sad because it it may end
up causing a divide and stronger
boundaries that you're going to have to
set yeah no I I I agree the the thing
that I kept pushing for was they could
do it too you know that's what hard my
heart was I'm not trying to withhold
from them I'm trying to you know like I
I'll walk with you I'll tell you exactly
how I did it I wrote it all down you
know I I'll keep my budgets in paper you
know I can tell you how I did it and
yeah there's a lot of luck and a lot of
things but you know you you we could do
it together like I'll help you you know
and they're just no I'm not interested
in working I mean they used to make fun
of me in the beginning when I said oh
yeah I was gonna follow Dave Ramy plan
they're like no don't don't do that you
know that's not gonna make any money
like all right I me he seems to like his
wife and his life I want to do that too
you know like yeah that's and that was
my heart I was like they're not
interested in learning entitlement runs
far away from work that's generally how
it goes and so I love the old quote I
think it's a my angeloo quote when
someone shows you who they are believe
them the first time and if they show
their character that this relationship
is based on transactions and your forced
generosity then it's not a relationship
and they're choosing to opt out of that
relationship if that's how they see you
and so the hardest part about all this
is you grappling with the emotions of
that has nothing to do with them it's
you feeling like I'm not the bad guy
here cuz they're going to Gaslight you
and go man you're evil I can't that
you're so you're so stingy after
everything we did for you remember when
you were five and I took you there's
going to be all kinds of things that
bubble to the service
now yeah that's what you pretty much
nailed what my dad said yeah 100% hit
him right on the head dang yeah man it
was an odd conversation it's odd place
to be but you know I don't know I was
thinking that maybe maybe the best
course would be you know bend the knee a
little bit and just best course is uh I
don't flee the and change your name but
let's not do that you know the witness
yeah the right course is have the hard
conversations as many times as you need
to and then you need to draw the line
and say listen we've talked about this
several times this is where I stand on
it I love you guys but our relationship
can't be based on transactions yeah and
again they're choosing this
like that you haven't done anything
you've just done the hard work for five
six years is a good man I know and and
this is what is being exposed in them
and you can't control them as much as
your heart is so good and pure and
wanting that you can't and I think it's
going to be it's going to continue to
create that divide and you're you're
going to continue not to want to let
them into your life which is so sad with
family so I'm so sorry Seth I hope you
feel encouraged though you're doing good
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a g God send for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
the Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services there are a lot of
things that you need to remember when
the winter when the weather is cold
thankfully neighborly has a free winter
maintenance checklist that can help save
you time and hassle check out
neighbor.com Ramsey that's neighborly
dcom Ramsey today's question comes from
Britney in Nevada or is it
did I say it right yeah you did Nevada
are you sure I don't think it is now I
feel bad for everyone it's Nevada that's
what it is no it's Nevada Britney asks
my sister only makes around 25,000 a
year and recently found out our mom took
out a credit card in her name which has
a balance of
$2,000 our mom habitually has no money
and I don't see a world where she will
pay this debt off I ran a credit report
and as far as I can tell she does not
have one in my name I make $72,000 a
year and have been thinking about saving
up to pay this debt so it's not hanging
over my sister anymore is this a good
idea and how do we close this
account oof man well there's a lot going
on here most of it's relational only
part of it
Financial yeah I mean I mean it's
illegal she stole her identity fraud and
so I mean and I know people don't and
it's hard to take legal action on $2,000
do and against your mom that makes
things extra awward yes I'm like um
and
so oh my gosh yeah so what you would do
is yeah you to in order to close the
account you have to have it paid off
paid in full then you close the account
um and then I would put you know as much
protection around all of your crediting
freeze every account with all three
credit bureaus immediately and just
making sure that yeah no one especially
her but but also having the conversation
with her like she needs to be confronted
absolutely that this happened you guys
have the knowledge of it
I mean and I'm like and and you hate to
threaten someone but I'm like you you
literally stole my identity and took out
money in my name to somebody that makes
$25,000 a year and so going forward it's
like if you if you continue to have to
have a legal action against me I'm going
to have to Pro like we're going to have
to move forward with something harsher
mom and so I don't know again $2,000 for
some people they would go ahead and like
do as much as they could by the law to
get this stopped because I guess she
could get re right if it's considered if
it's considered fraud she reports it and
says she won't have to pay it but then
the but and again in some like world
where you're like yes Justice needs to
be served but then in the real world I'm
like it's $2,000 and how much you're
going to pay a lawyer to do everything I
don't know yeah my first go would be
contact the credit card company say hey
this is fraud this was not a purchase I
made and have them try to reverse that
and secondly uh like Rachel said I would
close this account pay it off and if the
sister wants to do that as a gift which
it sounds like Britney's wanting to do
that that's very sweet I that's a
onetime thing and go hey I'm going to
cover this and we're going to fix this
and freeze all of your accounts with all
the credit bureau so this never happens
again and then confronting mom is the
piece is the another piece of this yeah
and helping sister get her income up
that to me is another glaring problem
outside of this but right making $12 an
hour is not sustainable longm for an
adult long term yes yes and we don't
know how old she is or what her
situation is but um she may be 16 for
all we know I have no idea that's so
hard and that's become and it's become a
common thing George like we're seeing
more and more of this uh I'm seeing it
on Tik Tok and Instagram and people are
going oh open a card in your kids's name
add them as add them as an authorized
user at 3 years old so they have great
credit when they graduate and then you
tank your kids credit accidentally or
maliciously happens and a pandemic hits
and you get strapped for cash and you
have to go make financial decisions that
are not wise in a crisis and your kid's
name is attached to it and so again yeah
we're seeing like but that in above
itself is that legal that's not I mean
to add them as an authorized user yeah
that's legal but open one in their name
no no that's illegal yeah yeah yeah
without yeah obviously they're you can't
ask a a three-year-old for consent so
you just add them as an authorized user
which that's what parents are doing in
the legal aspect of it but again it ends
up we see the horor stories and we've
had people call the show same thing
happening my parents tank my credit what
do I do they open up cards on my name or
added me as a user on this card and it's
affecting me financially yes yeah there
was a um a study by Carnegie melon and
this was in 2011 so again it was um few
years back but found that children are
uniquely vulnerable to identity theft
and in their analysis more than 40,000
American children researchers at their
University found that 10 % of them had
someone else using their social security
number oh gosh and then in 2011 a study
came out uh that found one in 50 US
children fall victim to identity theft
every year with 73% of victims being
targeted by someone they know personally
goodness which is probably going to be a
parent an aunt an uncle a brother a
sister that's terrible and so much of it
is financially related right sing your
identity to open up accounts and credit
cards they say here U the founder of the
law firm said the chief motivation
behind these crimes was when a parent
has had bad credit and is not able to
make a debt-based purchase there you go
and it says in Most states this is a
crime fraud identity theft Mis
appropriation of funds are all possible
charges a prosecutor could bring y so
it's possible to go to court for this
but again the costs of lawyer fees add
up to where you're like was this I spent
10 grand to fight two grand was this
worth it in the end and a lot of stress
sure emotional termo yeah yeah and again
you want Justice in every legal sense of
the word right but um but when you get
down to it in the real world it's like
oh my gosh for somebody out there her
making $72,000 a year it's like is it
realisic for her to go and yeah go and
hire a lawyer and do all of this you
know or do you pay it close the accounts
have the threatening conversation with
mom um but yeah some people see some
people choose the latter so we'll see
choose
violence never all right up next we have
Bailey in Pittsburgh hey Bailey welcome
to the
show hi thank you for taking my call and
thank you to you too and your team for
what you do oh thank you I appreciate
that how can we
help so years ago back when everything
was paper I I you know started following
um your dad at that time and then kind
of got off track and here recently in
the last month have just you know came
back around and I'm trying to convince
my husband to you know let follow
program to a te which means stopping our
investing in our 401ks and things like
that um he's a numbers guy so I thought
he would get it but I can't he doesn't
seem he says that's leaving money on the
table and I'm saying let's do it
temporarily so we can pay off some
debt okay so how much debt do you guys
have um around 40,000 on a
vehicle
7500 on a credit
card and he's a numbers
guy yeah does he know what the APR is on
that credit card uh yeah does he know
what that car will have costed him after
all the payments and interest versus
what it's worth after the term is over
I'm not the numbers person and I've laid
all that out which if I can that's what
my frustration is and I I say to him you
know we we've done some things okay
through our years like for example after
this year we'll have three children
through college we fully paid for that
so they're not coming out with
debt how much you guys make Bailey I'm
sorry how much you guys make a year
household income
um uh combin now just recently took a
new job so combined now we're at 250
W well yeah I mean you guys have the
margin to for sure pause the investing
and pay this off I mean I know you know
that um at the end of the day too Bailey
I'm like and also the truth is even if
you guys continue to you know do because
how much you putting in retirement
now he's he's maxing his and I'm maxing
mine and that's what I'm saying to him
you know let's just pause that I'm not
saying let's stop it I'm just saying
let's pause it pay off some of this
other stuff because do you guys have
money in savings
we have um 10 liquid cash 10,000 liquid
cash that I you know something Happ I
could yeah well and then the truth is
Bailey over time you know if you guys
didn't pause it and you guys just threw
some extra money and got this debt paid
off you're going to be fine either way
my biggest red flag is that you guys are
just not on the same page on your value
system so obviously your passion is more
on getting out of debt and I would and I
would present not just the number Zone
but the why why is it for you Bailey is
it because it's stressing you out are
you fearful do you see oh my gosh we're
empty nesters now and what we could be
doing if we didn't have all these
payments and and I'm stressed that we're
going to go deeper into debt because
that's a part of our life right
explaining the why not just the numbers
to hel spouse to spouse is really
[Music]
important if you're like most people
your home is your most valuable asset
and when you want to make improvements
it feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May apply
[Music]
so one of the topics that is really
popular I'd say in in this line of work
George but also in the world right now
is Real Estate top we are so excited to
announce that dve Ry has a brand new
quick readout which means it's a pretty
short book is 7 over coffee yep 70
pages and it's called The Real Estate
the Ramsay way how to make home
ownership a blessing not a burden and
Dave has yeah decades and Decades of
real estate knowledge being an agent
himself started at 18 started at 18 he
made his first few Millions yep lost it
all through real estate learned a lot
and back largely through real estate
which is cool what a comeback story all
the way around I know
360 just back back and in this book
right you I love that from start to
finish you'll get a clear plan to help
you buy sell and invest in ways that
will let you build outrageous wealth and
leave a legacy there is a right way to
do it home ownership is still possible
in America today and your home can be
your biggest asset it doesn't have to be
complicated we can do this the right way
Dave is going to show you how so get
your copy at ramseys solutions.com store
I know a lot of you are wanting to buy a
home you have people in your life who
are wanting to buy a home or they're
about to sell a home they want to get
into real estate investing this is a
great gift to get for them as well yeah
for sure and we want to yeah give hope
that that it is so possible you guys but
we want you to do it the right way so it
is all here so again whether you're
buying for your primary home investing
in real estate all of it real estate the
Ramsey Way at ramseys solutions.com
store up next we have Mark in
Minneapolis hey Mark welcome to the
show ah yeah thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we
help well I wanted to know if you guys
had dealt with any uh anything like a
promiser note um being repaid um it's uh
I have a promiser note kind of hanging
over my head about
$26,000 from a previous job um uh the
contract was or I was supposed to stay
there for two years I left for personal
reasons uh only had about 3 months left
until the two years was up um but now
it's with an attorney and uh we just we
don't have anywhere near that amount of
money to to pay I just don't know if you
guys have ever heard of getting out of a
promisory note or what do you think I I
should do well I mean this is a legal
contract that you signed and it said hey
you get $26,000 what was this for
relocation uh yeah relocation and if you
leave within the two years you owe us
this money
back correct M and so you broke that
contract and there are consequences for
breaking contracts and one of those is
you owe
$26,000 so what happened to the 26 did
you spend it
all oh yeah yeah I mean we used it for
relocation went from from Texas over
here so what made you leave three months
before the contract was
up uh I I just knew that I wasn't going
to be able to honestly fulfill the the
duties of the role and the travel just
took too much time away from from my
family and I wanted to to be with the
family okay that's that's what I
prioritized okay um but you knew you
would owe this upon
quitting like this wasn't a surprise
some yeah cont well yeah when I when I
quit my my boss said he he wasn't sure
that they would actually um do anything
but he didn't really know and they
enforced
it yeah it's with a with an attorney
right now and they've contacted you and
and expecting some type of
payment uh correct other than trying to
settle and negotiate there's no way to
scirt around the law if you sign the
contract so your best bet is to listen I
don't have
$26,000 are you willing to negotiate a
smaller payment to call this good that's
what I would do if I was in your shoes
do you guys have any money saved
Mark no and I'm sure we could talk for
hours on on our situation but yeah we
have no money okay how much are you
making a year now uh I uh I make a 100
okay does your wife
work yeah she makes um about 60 60 okay
so you take home pay one 160 um um
household income and what what other
debt do you guys
have um quite a bit I would
say uh from credit cards to some
consolidation loans around 100 okay how
much is in the credit
cards
um right now only
about
14,000 okay and the remaining is a debt
consolidation
loan
uh yeah like three of them yeah
okay um so Mark you realize the
decisions you guys have made up until
this point with money not great right do
is that a consensus between you and your
wife like how you guys have been doing
money isn't
working oh yeah no yeah 100% okay okay
um and I hate that this 26,000 will be
added to this list I'm afraid it will be
I mean there's nothing unless they will
settle like George said said um I think
you guys are just going to be on a hard
journey here for the next few years
digging yourselves out of these mistakes
and listen Mark nobody's perfect with
money so that's not a shameful thing
like nobody's perfect right before you
came on we talked about how Dave went
bankrupt you
know got foreclosed on by doing bad
investment deals like every like from
one extreme to the next like nobody here
is perfect but also you have to realize
okay what we've been doing isn't working
and so now we have to change not just
our mind set around how we've been
looking at money cuz it's not working
but we're going to change our habits
it's going to feel different our life is
going to look different but something
has to change in order to get a
different result and you guys have to
get at that point we call it the sick
and tired moment around here that people
get to this point where like I'm so done
I'm so done and Mark I hope this
$226,000 you know situation is the thing
that just shakes you to your core that
you're like holy crap I we can't keep
doing this because so far you've tried
debt consolidation trying to move your
stuff around for interest rates and for
all the other reasons people do it but
you have to realize what's going to
change your situation is you mark you
and your wife not some company out there
and so that's going to take you guys
learning a new set of principles and a
new set of skills um but that is very
possible and I want that for you as we
sit here on this call and you have to
want it for yourself but um but to
answer yeah your question on why you
called in um I I don't think there's
there's much you can do with the 26,000
unless they'll settle
or try to get on a payment plan of some
sort to pay this over time yeah but the
good news is Mark you guys make
$160,000 so let just lay out some napkin
math for you if you're able to live on a
smaller portion of that and throw 50 a
year at your debt you're done two and a
half years from now you're completely
debt free even the relocation
money think about that yeah I feels like
a long time but you could just sit
around for two and a half years and
continue to move around debt with
consolidation loans or we could really
make some deep sacrifices and be done
and have freedom in 2 and a half years
and never touch Deb again that would be
my goal for you
personally yeah that would be that would
be amazing well the math says it's
possible but you have to believe it's
possible and then your actions have to
follow okay so that's the plan there's
no way around it I'm sorry you're going
through this it stinks but I hope it's
the wakeup call you needed to go we got
to clean our life up yeah and stay on
the line Mark Austin will pick up and
we're going to give you Financial Peace
University which is our seven lesson
course and every dollar premium which is
our budgeting app which is going to help
you guys look at your lifestyle and say
hey we're we're doing nothing like we
say beans and rice rice and beans you
don't go out to eat you don't go on
vacation you do nothing and there's
going to be an extremeness to all of
this because I mean 14,000 in credit
card debt for the most part I'm going to
assume Mark that yeah a lot of that's
just the lifestyle creep of like we're
just going to continue to live and spend
where we want and and and you have to
get to Point you say all that's done all
that's done and it's a hard Line in the
Sand you cut up the credit cards tonight
you and your wife sit down together cut
them up be done with this Mark be done
with this I mean I I I can only imagine
the stress that you guys were in already
with 100K in debt and then you get this
call from this attorney of this yeah
relocation you know fee that's that's
that cost that's owed now um which
legally it is owed and so I I want this
to be your wakeup call we can't force
that on on this side of of the
death we want it for you though we want
you and your wife and your family to
experience Freedom like it's Life's Too
Short Mark to be living like this and I
think that for for a lot of you out
there it just takes it it takes an
extreme mindset shift though and an
extreme way of looking at something so
different than how you've always looked
at it and that's one of the hardest
parts towards for people it's just the
change like it's going to feel
uncomfortable able not living with
credit card you're enjoying extreme
spending and now it's extreme sacrifice
yes and it's going to it's going to feel
off it's it feels like you're going
backwards but I'm telling you if you
stick to this watch these videos in
Financial Peace University do the every
dollar budget you and your wife together
and in two and a half years as George
laid out the math you guys can be done
and have a whole new set of skills with
for investing and Building Wealth and
changing your family tree so we're
cheering for you mark thanks for the
call thanks to all the gentlemen in the
booth keeping the show afloat and see
you George thank you thank you America
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with bestselling Author George
camel answering your questions so give
us a call at8 825
5225 all right let's hit the phones
George go straight to it let's go to
Tori in Louisville Kentucky hey Tori
welcome to the show hi thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help well I have some well I need some
advice on what you all would suggest my
husband and I do to pay off our debt um
my husband is currently working two
full-time jobs and going to school um so
we are making the most we have ever made
however we are both miserable because
he's never home and I have taken on the
majority of the house work with our
children um and I also work so my
question is do we power through like
we're currently doing um to pay off our
debt quicker or would you suggest that
he scales back on his work we buckle
down titer on our budget and pay off the
debt which might take a little bit
longer okay how much debt is left we
have 75,000 okay and how much are you
guys making currently with him working
two jobs you working a full-time job we
bring home an average of 10,000 a month
okay what kind of debt is the
75 we have two car
loans um a home equity loan two credit
cards and then one student student loan
for him but it is deferred at this time
but it is included in that that 75,000
okay what's he going to school
for uh to he's nurse practitioner okay
so when is that over that schooling two
and a half two and a half years wow okay
he's working two full-time jobs while
becoming an
MP yes this man's impressive so he is he
is a firefighter so he actually does
24hour shift goodness on his days off he
teaches at our community college he
teaches the nursing classes so by the
time he gets home he is exhausted it
really has affected our whole lives our
marriage our children our health sure
sure what's the current trajectory if
you keep all of this in your life how
soon will you be out of
debt that is a good question so we
recently have not been great with our
money so we recently just January 1
started working with a Dave or with a
ramay coach on our budget um so we've
we've completed baby St one um so I'm
not I would think within probably 18
months maybe how much are you throwing
at the debt total including extra
payments well we've just hit baby step
one so so T so you guys have been
working this much where was the money
going out the window so did you increase
your lifestyle as he took on the extra
jobs I mean we did so we we bought the
two vehicles I would sell these these
cars I don't know what they're worth and
what you owe on them but that feels like
a better sacrifice than losing your
husband right now sure I'd rather yeah
what what are the car numbers for us
real quick yeah so my I have my vehicle
um we owe about 23 on it okay I recently
looked at what it was worth because I
was considering selling upside down
probably it's about yeah about $2,000
upside down it's about 21 I do private
Sal it's not huge okay now my my poor
husband he purchased a truck and it is
he he it is the worst worst thing we've
ever purchased it is the worst lemon
ever he doesn't even feel comfortable
selling it to anybody so he's just kind
of driving it around as little as he can
how much is it he we owe um 6,800 on
that okay okay that's you think it's
worth about that if you're lucky or what
oh he doesn't even think we could get
that out of it okay so Tori how long
sorry how long have you guys been on the
schedule the 90 hour a week schedule
he's about two and a half
years so why Tori I'm I'm a little bit
confused because usually when we talk to
people on this show just in this
perspective they're working two three
jobs they're going crazy because they're
putting extra money to the debt they're
doing it for a reason why did you guys
choose to do this life style two and a
half years ago working
wise I think we were just you know we
weren't good with our money at that
point okay and so it's just to keep your
life afloat yeah just to keep going okay
okay
um because what I would say Tori is that
this level of sacrifice we've seen
people do it and they do it for a period
of time maybe not maybe not two years
but you know a good six nine months and
then maybe they take a break for a
little bit then bring on an extra job to
get out of debt right they're doing all
this for a purpose so if that was the
case there's a part of me that would say
Okay um you know if someone was calling
in and they hadn't done it yet but
they're like we're looking into this if
we just power through for two years we
could get all this cleaned up like I I
feel like I would be like yes yes yes
you guys have been doing it for 2 and
half years just to keep your lifestyle
afat which obviously is more of a
lifestyle than what you were you know
expecting cuz you guys went into debt
for it too um and so I don't want you I
don't I don't want 90 hours a week to be
the norm on how to just support your
life right like that's not I don't want
you call us 2 and a half years from now
being like well we still have 75 in debt
and he's still doing this so we need an
endgame here and that's what we're
trying to show you and based on math if
you bring 10 home a month you said can
you put five of that toward debt because
that would get you debt free in 15
months and like like live on nothing
Tori like
nothing so I yes we could I did like our
what our four walls um yeah payments
would be and it was about
4,000 35 3500 perfect so that means
there should be in a perfect world
$6,500 of take-home pay left to throw at
debt with minimum payments plus extra
M yeah and once you do that math with
the debt snowball calculator you should
be debt free in a
year
yeah I can do about anything for a
year you're calling us though two and a
half years after all of this so you guys
are exhausted like two and a half years
of n i mean like that's it's not
sustainable long term right that's what
how you guys are doing it it's not and I
wouldn't recommend that long term for
anybody the second full-time job would
it just take an extra year cuz I'm okay
with that if this takes two years for
you guys to clean up and you survive it
yeah mhm yeah but here's the deal Tori
I'm like you guys have to be so
committed to this process because if
you're not you will look up in two years
and hadn't made much of a a dent in this
if you're not like really committed to
that process you know and maybe you guys
stay on Tori through through the summer
and maybe in the fall he he pulls back
you know it doesn't have to be today but
you guys kind of do a game plan and just
say but but we understand like we're
we're parents we're human like we know
that it takes a lot of sacrifice and we
don't want your mental health to be an
issue you know we we don't want um this
idea that parents are just Workaholics
and they're far away but but people do
all the sacrifice and do what you're
doing for a goal of becoming debt free
so that they don't have to do this
anymore right so um so there's a reason
for the sacrifice and we're all for that
but you guys have been doing it for 2
and a half years and you haven't made
any progress so my fear is if you you if
you kind of pull back from the work
side uh you know H have your money
habits really change so I would just um
yep tell you guys if you can do it for a
little bit longer and maybe bring in
some of that income and then really get
into the habit of budgeting living on
nothing putting money and once that
habit really is instilled then maybe you
pull back a little bit from work knowing
it's going to take you a little bit
longer cuz I don't want you guys uh yeah
to be suffering for too long unable
that's right yep but you guys got this
Tory you can do this
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to netw Suite it works for us
and it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll company
netsuite can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use Nets to know their
numbers and their business better so
check out netw Suite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
one of the principles that we really
push people towards is savings so
whether you're saving for an emergency
fund saving up for a down payment on a
home for a purchase buying a car
vacation and where to put that savings
is a question George I feel like I get a
lot on social media and different things
probably the number one question I get
in the DMS is y what's a good high yield
savings account you guys talk about this
so we're going to talk about what a high
yield savings account is in you just
went to the punch line oh was I ruined
back up back up all go back up 10
seconds so people always ask George you
know on social media where should I save
this money should I save it you know in
a just a savings account do I it what
you know there's high yield savings
accounts there's money market accounts
like there's all these places do I yeah
do I invest into the market what do I do
and one of the places we always talk
about investing is a high yield savings
account oh that's right George post tell
us to the produc about that I I'm just
so excited it's one of the things I love
the most couldn't wait to talk about an
old high yield savings SC but call H
ysas or heas for short no no no one
calls them that it's
God bless so this is just literally a
highin savings account the they're
generally online banks because the brick
and mortar Banks can't afford to Dole
out as high of a rate because they've
got a lot of overhead to pay for that's
right so uh traditional savings accounts
average about 35% on savings but plenty
of high yield savings accounts offer
rates of over four even over 5% which is
amazing yes yeah it's been incredible
and even when all the rates mortgage
rates you know everything has gone up
debt all the things Silver Lining saw
the other side yeah savings rates go up
and you know you earn more interest and
so that's what we really found and
Winston I we have a high yield savings
account we have one for our money market
and one just for short-term savings that
we just put put money in and and and I
love it again because you obviously get
a high rate of return for a savings
account right compared to a traditional
savings uh it's really safe uh you can
get your money out anytime for some
accounts you have a limited number of
transactions you can do per month you
can't use it as just like a full-on
checking account uh but you can it's
pretty easy to access and um yeah we use
Ali yep I use one called Marcus by
Goldman Sachs again we don't have a
Ramsay partner Advertiser in the space
but these are just the ones we
personally use so we can tell you at
least that much and the key is to do
your research on these I don't trust the
ones that are offered by credit card
companies or apple which makes you have
a Apple credit card to use their savings
account or Capital One or one of these
companies the big Banks and so while
these are huge companies you know Marcus
by Golden Sachs and Ally I have not
noticed they've been marketing debt
products or using my information to sell
me those prods that's a key here yeah we
would say though this is not a place to
park your money long term right so
investing don't mix it up savings is not
investing that's right two different if
you're getting some interest yeah and I
always say George my roll of thumb is
kind of that fiveyear Mark is that yours
or is yours shorter longer think yeah I
say depending on the situation 3 to five
plus years is that's I'm going to invest
that money versus Park it yep but you
know home down payment what worries me
Rachel people want to invest their down
payment and I go yeah but 3 years from
now what if the market took that dip at
the worst time when you want to buy that
house yes yes the 50 Grand turned into
40 Grand all of a sudden so that's risky
but a good example of this let's say you
are going to buy a house and you have
$110,000 saved in a high yield savings
at 5% well over the course of 12 months
in your sleep you're going to make $500
and if you have $ 100,000 doing the math
at 5% that's $5,000 over the course of
12 months that you would gain and a good
point Rachel here is that income is
taxable people don't realize that now
it's not the end of the world to get
taxed on 500 bucks or 5,000 bucks but
the interest you're accumulating yeah
that's is not free money yep that's a
great Point yeah and and the emergency
fund specifically you guys um that 3 to
six months like this is a great place to
park that and while we say it's not an
investment you want to be able to get to
it quickly so your your worry on that is
not oh my gosh am I making a high rate
of return it's really just the idea that
it is cushion I can get to it if I need
it something big comes up a job loss or
a medical emergency but while you're at
it you might as well put it in something
that's low risk and still make something
right so versus just putting it in a
traditional savings account it yeah high
Y savings accounts great but remember
your emergency fund is Insurance not an
investment this is money that's made to
protect you it's not made to make you
more money so don't be freaked out if
you're not getting a certain interest
rate at the end of the day it's not
going to be life-changing that's right
but I think it's a great option and
right now it's the highest rates I've
seen when my wife and I were saving up
for a house interest rates on savings
accounts were 2% I was jumping for joy
yes because of all the free money we
were getting from this 2% so now that
it's 5% or more goodness gracious I have
a lot of you know it's a great time to
be saving up for things because of that
reason that's right exactly yep and you
guys the way to find savings one of the
best things you can do is be budgeting
making sure you see okay here's my
income here's everything and we talk
about you know giving saving and
spending and what that looks like and
and to really be intentional with
putting money aside letting that be a
habit and so if you have never budgeted
before maybe you are a budgeter I really
recommend downloading every dollar it
really is the best way um there's a
savings category on every dollar so you
can kind of automate that and go all
right we're going to do a direct
transfer from our paycheck or bank
account to our savings account every
month and the budget will help you track
that and it's all right there yep so
every dollar is amazing for budgeting
and to get you in a position to be able
to say Say Yeah we actually can find
margin here and save some money again
for whether it's a car vacation down
payment emergency funds a high yield
savings account it's a great place to
park that shortterm make sure they are
FDIC insured or ncua if it's a credit
union that's a good point to call out so
when you're on the website which the
ones we mentioned are but you want to
make sure that it's insured uh I think
it's up to $250,000 per depositor so
that's right pretty sweet it's good all
right let's go to the phones we have
Aiden in Dallas hey Aiden welcome to the
show all thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we
help I'm just I'm getting ready to
purchase a new truck I'm just trying to
figure out what truck yeah oh George
loves a trucken really how much I can
really afford when it comes to being a
truck buying a truck or would be smart
all right how much you make a year
Aiden uh this year I will gross anywhere
in between from 95 to about 115 okay
amazing and what debt do you
have uh my my current vehicle will be
paid off in about two months I
ow about 300 to my Mac dealer and a
little a little under 500 to my Cornwell
dealer okay and how much do you have in
savings to buy the truck
uh I have about eight but that's I'm
trying not to touch that so I can keep
on growing that for uh down payment mon
house
8,000 yes I plan on trading in my
current
vehicle trading in for another like a
truck with a payment on
it yes what kind of truck are you gonna
buy I'm still trying to build my
credit what was that what truck are you
looking to buy I'm looking to buy 2500
or 3500 diesel what
year uh early 2000 early 20
to uh late 2010s okay and what is that
going to cost you
think uh it um all all depends
anywhere I can get the trucks I'm
looking at I could get one for anywhere
between about 20 to
40 okay that's a big
range well Aiden you're probably not
going to like our
answer if you listen back to this call
Aiden you're going to hear that you have
a lot of priorities right now don't
don't you yes you're trying to pay off
debt you're trying to buy a house you're
trying to get this truck and I found
that when people are doing too many
things at once they don't really make
progress on any of them and it usually
leads to poor financial
decisions and right now you can turn the
ship around pretty quick I mean making a
100 Grand and you've got what a few
thousand in debt
left uh yeah not much and so we can
clean up all of your debt within three
or four months
yes and in fact you have $88,000 right
now you could use to pay off the car and
pay off all of your debt you could be
debt free
today yes and that would leave you with
how much in savings
still a few
thousand yeah a few thousand there you
go so that's going to be your starter
emergency fund yeah that'll be your
starter emergency fund Aid and and then
what other C whatever cash you have
beyond that you can put with the truck
you're going to trade in and you only
are going to buy a truck that you can
pay for no more payments because debt is
stealing this income and especially with
a car you are taking a loan out and
paying interest on an asset that's going
down in value mathematically it is not a
smart move Aiden so I would stick with
the truck you have pay it off drive that
for a while save up and pay cash for
your next six months from now you're
going to be able to save up and pay cash
for it yep don't let the bank steal all
your income Aiden don't give them
[Music]
payments
hey guys you know this but I'll say it
anyway college is freaking expensive and
student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000 so if you're in over your head
with private student loan debt don't
beat yourself up look we've all made
mistakes with money in the past what
matters is doing something about it now
so if you're in distress with private
student loans that's private not federal
student loans call Y refi y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay to learn
more about this custom refinancing
option call 844 to Ramsey or go to Y
rei.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
[Music]
so one of the things we love to do
around here George is put on events we
love a good live event we love a good
live event our team is really good at
them yes some of the best events in the
country and sometimes we're out
traveling to different cities but this
time George we're going to do one in our
backyard here at RC Solutions up on the
hill in our new event center and we are
doing The Total Money Makeover weekend
you guys so this is going to be a full
weekend on May 10th and 11th
and we are going to help people when it
comes to the subject that we talk about
all the time which is money so actually
the night before on the 10th George and
I we may or may not be doing a live
recording of smart money happy hour our
podcast so you can come and participate
in that and then an all day event that
next Saturday with all the ramsy
personalities and it's going to be
really fun we're going to talk through
obviously the baby steps and different
parts of your money and your life and
we're going to do lots of Q&A as well we
find that people you know have whether
it's specific situations or even you
know just the generic problems that we
all run into when it comes to money uh
but to be able to have conversations
with you guys throughout the weekend is
really important to us so it's going to
be it's going to be really fun ear laor
tickets are only $99 only for a limited
time and if you want to get the best
deal on tickets again this is it so go
ahead and buy your buy your seats buy
your tickets because we only have 2400
available and so you can do that ramsy
solutions.com
events love it people come from all over
the country even the world to come to
these events which is so amazing so go
start budgeting for the travel and
transportation and lodging and all the
fun stuff and Nashville is a great place
just to hang out so extend your trip and
enjoy it while you're here ramsy
solutions.com events May 10th and 11th
looking forward to that yes love to hang
out with you guys all right up next we
have Sarah in Charlotte hey Sarah
welcome to the show hi thank you so much
for having me um so my question for you
guys is uh currently my husband and I
are renting an apartment um for about
32% of our uh net
income and in order to get closer to
that 25% we have to move to a lowincome
house like a lowi income community and
I'm not sure uh if that's wise you know
because sometimes uh crime is higher in
low income communities um um I just
wanted to know if you guys had any takes
on whether we should jump from our 32 to
25% by finding a cheaper apartment and a
low-income Community or what you
think I appreciate your intensity for
the plan but that 25% is really a
guideline and it's not a set in stone if
you're at 26 time to move bucko so I
don't think this is on fire you guys
sound like you're doing a good job
paying attention to every dollar and my
assumption is your income will go up
over the next year
correct um potentially U my husband put
in some applications to become a police
officer and it could potentially go up a
little bit but he it's going to stay
about the
same okay yeah I mean I would say Sarah
I mean obviously we don't want you know
you in a situation that maybe you feel
unsafe or whatever you know it may be
for you um I mean yeah you want to be
able to find a place that that you feel
good at and and I would say too that um
you know just because a situation is
different doesn't always you know make
it bad right and so um I think there can
be some places that you may Overlook
because of just the thought of oh gosh
you know the high crime or whatever it
may be but to really do your research
and dig in because there's parts of
cities you know that may be lower income
but they're great neighborhoods and
great people and all of it so I would I
would do my due diligence to really look
and see um I mean ultimately I want you
to feel safe I mean I think that's
that's a that's a fair value to have in
life um but also you know to to maybe
look at yeah maybe our life maybe where
we are though where we live will look
different than maybe what we thought
because of our income and George is
right like that 25% it is a guideline
there um but when it starts to creep up
in that 35 40% of your take home pay
that's what it does it just limits the
amount of income that you can use for
other things like getting out of debt
and investing and all of that so how
much you guys make in a
year uh we make about 55,000 okay my
husband works and I'm a stay at home mom
okay how old are your
kids I my son he's almost 10 okay that's
great so great yeah so I mean I think
you guys talk about it look at the
budget do you guys have a lot of
debt uh we do but uh luckily it's just
to a family member who paid off our debt
so okay how much is that we don't have
um it's almost 50,000 okay okay and are
you guys working on getting rid of
that uh we are yeah okay that's great
yeah and once that's freed up you know
that that's going to
feel a little more is it a monthly
payment you're
making yeah we're trying to do a monthly
payment and it's pretty low right now
like if we keep right now we're only uh
trying to give about 250 a month so
that'll take us like 10 years to pay him
off goodness gracious yeah I wouldn't do
that I would be changing something in
that formula which is probably going to
be the income um on making more I mean
you know and what's so hard Sarah is um
you know math it is what it is right and
so being able to look and say okay this
is the amount of money that we have and
so we want to be wise with it we want to
be on a very strict budget and know
exactly where that's going um but I also
don't want this debt hanging around you
guys for 10 years to a family member and
even though they're probably not
charging you interest from a relational
standpoint it's just it just gets weird
over time and so um they'll see you go
on vacation and go whoa whoa whoaa they
owe us money and they're going on this
trip yeah that's right that's right even
once you're out of debt y so I would
just make a plan to pay that off more
aggressively and that might mean making
more income but the point of the 25%
guideline is so that you're not house
poor is so that you have more money to
pay off debt and so again nothing's on
fire here but I would make a plan to
increase income over the next 12 months
to to create more margin to get rid of
this Tad faster that's great all right
up next we have Larry in Evansville hey
Larry welcome to the show hey guys
thanks for taking my call today how you
doing we're doing great how can we
help so um I'm recently found you guys
and I'm really trying hard to figure out
budgeting type things uh I grew up in a
family that you know didn't really care
about it you know and I'm trying to
figure it out and I've looked at every
dollar and I'm just overwhelmed with
things like I try and budget and then
something comes up and it's just very
overwhelming and it's just I'm to the
point of I'm tired of you know living
every paycheck to paycheck and you know
the next week I'm broke and it's just
hard and I'm I just need help budgeting
I need to figure out like what where do
I start like what's the problem right
now when you say I feel broke and are
the are there too many bills after your
paycheck show
up so what happened is um you know a
couple years ago I got I I I did some
bad things I got addicted to some things
after an accident I hadn't you know I I
I I screwed up our family and when I did
that it made a lot of death for my
family I'm sorry you're okay and I'm
trying to get out of
this and I I try so hard I work you know
65 hours a week and it's just I don't
know I I honestly can't tell you exactly
where it's going you know I I I am
paying down the debt that I'm doing but
then also you know car repairs come up
uh my kids need something yeah yeah how
many kids do you have I have three how
old are
they uh two five and eight wow so you
guys you guys have been through you've
been through a lot Larry for over the
last what how how long has this journey
been for you guys and are you sober now
I've been I've been sober for over a
year now a great guy from Boston you
know took me up there and helped me out
and yeah it's just the last six years
before that you know I was working but
I'd leave the job because you know
something would happen or I wouldn't go
to work and you know I'd get behind on
things and you know I say oh I'll push
this off for now and it's all this
coming back to haunt me and I'm I'm
trying so hard the budget
money more you think so Larry we're
coming up on a break if you'll hold on
the line we'll come back back to you if
that's okay in our next segments just to
kind of walk through more of your story
and to help you with just the overall
picture CU I think budgeting for sure is
a piece of it um but there's a lot of
life in there and possibly some debt we
can run some numbers and kind of help
you walk away with the game plans that's
sound good yeah I appreciate it okay
absolutely so hold on the line yep hold
on the line hold on the line Larry and
you guys listening and watching right
now we will be
back
[Music]
welcome back we were just talking to
Larry this segment before and he was
asking us really how how do you start
budgeting what does this look like if
you're just new to this process because
it just feels like something always
continues to come up
for kids yes throughout the month and
they've walked a a hard journey um he
was telling us with just some addiction
and he's been sober a year and they're
really trying to get in this place where
they can get control of their money was
that a good summary
Larry yeah okay wonderful okay so tell
me this Larry how much how much do you
guys make in a year just household
income uh so uh my wife makes about 30
about 28 before taxes um and then me uh
you know I just started back working
about a year ago and this past year I
made about 51 you know consistent saying
you know with the same employer that's
great what do you
do I I work in home healthcare I work
with like mentally handicapped
individuals okay it's uh something I've
I've Loved for a while yeah that's great
that's great so you guys are making
around around 80
81,000 and what debt do you guys
have uh so uh we have a a car that got
repoed a couple years ago that I because
of me that I'm working to pay off just
to you know get that out of there yeah
um we got my wife's car now that you
know we had to have because we had to
have reliable transportation for her how
much is that how much is
that um it's about eight uh right now
8,000 okay and how much is it with that
you're repaying for the the
repossession I'm about 14 um okay I had
bought it for about 16 but uh I was 14
and you know just basically stopped
paying yeah okay so the two cars what
else and then uh we have uh combined
between like just little loans that we
tried to get to get by um you know and
Loans to family we have about you know
15 there okay um you know and then
medical debt we have about 6,000 but I'm
trying to get some assistance from like
their financial aid there but you know
that's just a process of trying to get
that figured out right now for sure
anything else any credit card
debt uh Lo that's that's in with like
the the 15 you know there's some credit
cards uh which is about uh you know
1,500 of it okay the rest is loans like
family little loans just here and there
that you know I I thought would you know
get me by to where I need to be and then
I found you guys and you know realized
that like there's something I'm doing
wrong and you know I I finally built up
the courage and off the embarrassment
that I have to you know call you guys
and you know just figure it out and yeah
I'm tired of it yeah well I'll tell you
this I think you've won probably the
hardest battle money is nothing compared
to fighting and becoming sober and
walking that whole journey Larry so if
you can do that you can do this okay so
just hear me say that it's it's an
amazing thing when people finds freedom
in one area of their life it seems like
it opens up the door in other areas that
they they long for that same level of
Peace and Freedom you know that you've
found in that part of your life and now
that's transferring to your money and
money you know was and is possibly in
the present still a stressful a
stressful place but we want to be able
to to walk with you and and give you
just some peace for a plan you know and
and I think it's one of those things too
Larry that this can it can carry a lot
of Shame and a lot of guilt because the
hard thing with money is that you see
the numbers of the past that stay with
you and you have to you
face those and figure out what to do but
but just know what you've done in this
last year you can do this like you guys
together can do this process is your is
your marriage in a good spot you and
your wife or you guys on the same team
just at least from the financial
standpoint that you guys are went to
work a plan
together yeah I mean we we've talked
about it a lot and she just you know not
the best with math so she leaves it up
to me I don't want to you know stress
her out too much but you know I I talked
to her about it but I'm just still
ashamed of it to you know talk too much
okay okay so um yeah what I would
suggest as we start working through the
budget is I do want her to be involved
and she doesn't have to be the one that
you know is all excited about it and
like gets in there every day and all the
things but I want you guys to be in a
constant communication and be on the
same team uh because that's going to
help with these day-to-day things
because if the kids pipe up and want
something there's a good chance you guys
are going to look at them and say the
famous words I always heard growing up
it's not in the budget it's not in the
budget like there's going to be times
that you guys as a family are going to
have to make some hard decisions to make
these numbers work um and that's part of
the process right that you're that
you're learning how to do this and to
find margin so so in every dollar we
talk about yeah and as and you said
youve walk through it but your income
minus those expenses equaling zero and
we have on every dollar premium which
we'll give you after this call um if you
don't have that one already it's it's
our paid subscription part of every
dollar but what's so great is they have
a payment a paycheck planning
application within it and so what ends
up happening Larry we find that what's
difficult is you plan out your month and
you say okay we're going to spend you
know 600 on groceries and then but then
all of a sudden the the mortgage or the
rent hits the electricity bill like how
all the bills are lined up one paycheck
of the first isn't going to cover at all
right and you run out of money before
those bills are paid and so it'll help
you figure that out yeah and it feels
like you're broke in that sense and so
what the paycheck planning part of every
dollar does is it's able to show you hey
here's where you're getting close to the
red so what can you rearrange in your
budget to make sure that that paycheck
goes as far as you need it to go with
some cushion even till you're paid again
on you know the 15th or however often
you're paid and so that that money then
is going to be able to take you through
it and then there is a goal Larry I
would say from budgeting at least for me
George is that you're kind of a paycheck
ahead so you always have that cushion so
instead of using the money that just
hits your account you're kind of using
the money from the paycheck before even
um just to give you some breathing room
to not feel like oh my gosh our account
is getting down to zero right and so
that may take a few paycheck Cycles to
get in that place but um do you guys
have any money saved at all do you have
an emergency
fund no um okay you know I I've been
trying and anytime I do it and then you
know something comes up and yeah what
are the things that are coming up you've
mentioned that a few times what are
those kind of things uh you know just
at the beginning of the school year
school um you know my son you know has
gained weight and lost a lot of weight
and you know so we had to buy him a
holding you know wardrobe of clothes and
his mother who is not my wife currently
you know there's just a lot of you know
stuff going on there like she you know I
feel like sometimes I have to replace
her because she shows other people over
him and you know I try and
overcompensate I'm not going to lie to
nobody yeah and I'm to get past that but
yeah I hate seeing the way he's broken
because of it and yeah it's just messing
with me so
yeah which is very understandable I mean
I I see that and we see that a lot with
families that there is that
overcompensation of buying things for
kids or wanting that and and I'll tell
you Larry though at the end of the day
what he needs and what he wants is is
love and acceptance from the people in
his life and that's you and so I mean
and so that that is something that you
you are going to have to be the adult in
those situations and say you know that
this toy is not going to be the thing
that brings him lasting joy and
acceptance and love like it's it's just
not and so knowing that even though it
is so easy just to run to stuff and buy
stuff to make someone feel good for a
moment you know there Pro there will be
a boundary there so so I think that
there's going to be a level of
discipline that you and your wife I want
you to get on the same page with her and
say okay you know once we do this budget
it's done and the kids are going to ask
stuff is going to come up and we have to
say no we have to stick to this cuz I
want you to get $11,000 quickly if you
guys don't have any money saved even
getting a starter emergency fund of
$1,000 it's going to free you up and as
you go through every dollar again those
are places where you're going to be able
to say in categories okay we used to
spend this much and not to eat we're not
doing that and we're putting that aside
here like you you really do sit there
and take things away lower those
expenses and then for you if there is a
way to up some income for the season um
I think it's one of the best things that
you could do just to bring in some extra
money too to get that $1,000 and then
start working your way through this debt
and working your way to pay this debt
off and and I mean there there is hope
in this I mean we get these calls all
the time you make 80 and you owe 43 this
is a very fixable problem and it might
take two years but we can get out of
this so tactical things Larry uh you can
add a miscellaneous category to the
budget for some ankle biters you can
also do a print out your bank statement
and that way will you'll see a real
picture of what was spent in the last
few months that's going to help with
this budget as well yeah and give it
three months Larry I mean we're in
February March April give it April May
okay don't give up keep sticking with it
but hold on the line Austin will pick up
we're going to give you Financial Peace
University our seven lesson course on
money and every dollar premium uh just
to make sure that you guys um have the
the knowledge that you need as you start
this journey we're cheering for you this
is the Ramy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz and this
is George camel we are hosting this hour
of the show and we're taking your calls
at
88255 225 talking about your money your
life your relationships your work
anything and everything we are here for
you you so first up we have Jennifer in
Ventura California hi Jennifer welcome
to the show hey guys thank you so much
for taking my call thank you for all the
work you guys do I'm so blessed to be on
the call oh thank you thanks for calling
how can we
help uh I I guess I I kind of have AA
I'm brand new to you guys uh shout out
to Ventura Mission Church Ventura um I
will be doing BB set 3 lesson on Monday
so I'm like brand new that's Rachel we
did
that yeah I kind of took a sneak peek
like they gave us like a the little
barcode thing where they we get it for
free thank God thank you Church oh
that's awesome I took a sneak peek so I
saw my favorite speaker George you are
my favorite so cheers George he wins the
hearts many truth be told I told
Jennifer to call cuz she had a great
question for Rachel I like you need to
call Rachel's G to crush this question
with what Rachel's GNA crush this okay
so check it out Rachel so I I kind of
have a a case of like family fos so it's
not Keeping Up With the Jones is like I
I I drive an old van I've got old stuff
I learned my lesson I'm listening to you
guys I didn't know I'm 37 I'm like way
behind and I did not know any of this so
I'm like livetime learning it and I'm
I'm binging it right so but I've got one
of those uh super close families kind of
intrusively close families like we we do
everything together we're we have like a
Facebook Messenger kind of like a group
thread email Chat thing where we're like
it's literally like oh Paisley woke up
with the fever today and Ben got in
trouble with school it's like every
single thing like each other's Grill um
but that also includes like um like
let's do everything together like every
single Sunday let's have family dinner
especially because my dad passed away
it's been like every every Sunday let's
go to Nana's house and and and you and
don't show up empty-handed like what are
you gonna bring are you gonna bring ribs
are you gonna bring this and and I'm
calculating this in my head like there's
like 18 of us so for me to sign up for
drinks and buy everybody their favorite
drink I'm like way over like I can't so
often times I'm like oh gosh sorry guys
I'm volunteering church and I like I
like to pass and then it and then I get
the whole like under the breath like oh
well too bad you can't you know your
kids are missing out on family dinner
and and all that and all that stuff so
I'm just at a Crossroads and and I've
got that crafty sister that's always
like we're going to the zoo and I'm like
I can't afford the zoo oh there's a a
group on okay well it's a guas and it's
like you're taking time out of my side
house but like I can't do it all yeah
and my kids my kids see it the cousins
show them the pictures they all talk
about like oh look where we went and my
kids are like like why can't we go and
I'm just I'm just at that point where
there's only so much I could tell like
let's be content kids and my kids are
like I don't I want to be with my family
you know how old are your kids so my son
just turned nine in January and my
daughter will be 11 in May okay well I
think what's hard Jennifer is what's
happened in your life is you've
shifted a perspective right you've
shifted how you're viewing money you you
are shifting some you're changing
something about who Jennifer was n
months ago 12 months ago into you know a
new season right and I think you know we
we always parallel the financial world
with even the health world right it
would be the same thing if it was like
oh my gosh we're going to you know um go
I don't know eat a bunch of pizzas
you're like well I'm gluten George would
have to say no I'm I'm gluten-free
unless they have glutenfree crust I
can't go you know like so people even
with their nutrition right they draw
boundaries on what that is and I know
money's a little bit different but
anytime you change of what you're what
you're used to what people expect of you
the normaly of what was is not there
anymore and so I think that
acknowledgement is really hard and it's
hard when it plays into these kind of
smaller day-to-day interactions with
family and so I I mean have you just
bluntly said to them hey guys I'm living
on a strict budget now because I'm
trying to get out of debt and I can't be
doing all of this but I want to still
come to dinner I'm just going to bring
stuff you know cuz we're water people
now and you can kind of make fun of
yourself and be like sorry um but I
don't want y'all to like miss out on all
the good stuff I'm just choosing to miss
out for me but I don't want that to put
you guys out so y'all do you y'all plan
yourselves and I'll just bring my own
stuff I'll bring my you know grilled
cheeses and my water whatever it is that
you're choosing toally totally and and I
and I have I've been doing that I think
I think the bigger piece is the kid
probably my kids are what sping me most
cuz I my family like I'm the only one
that goes to church and my family I'm
the only one so I'm telling them about
this Ramy thing and they're like okay
it's another one of those weird Jennifer
things that's happen well I think you
mentioned to me also that their incomes
they're all making you know six figures
they're just at a different place in
life yeah and so honestly Jennifer the
gift to your kids even with family is to
say Hey how do we how do we learn to be
excited for somebody that has something
that we don't have and how can we still
have relationship with them right and
and I would hope your family would kind
of give a nod to where you guys are and
like okay yeah if we're going to the zoo
it is going to cost $30 for everyone to
go so we're going to choose not to do
that we'll go to the park or we'll come
over and do a play day like what other
things can we do that you can be a part
of as well right and maybe you throw out
those ideas but I think for your kids
and I get that I mean I understand
you're like I want them to be with
family and all that but but for them to
start to see that there are boundaries
in life and limits in life when it comes
to money and it's not just this endless
you know way of how to live you're
modeling that Jennifer and that's what
they're they're going to grow up with a
level of boundaries that's really great
and wonderful yeah but I also don't want
you to miss out on family time so I do
wonder if there's ideas that you can
even bring to the table to be like yeah
they don't you know I don't want to miss
out with you guys so I still want to
hang out you know and and I had a good
friend Jennifer who was going they were
going through some tight Financial spots
and and she was very honest with me and
and I knew and there was you know times
that it was like oh yeah we you know I
could take my kids to the zoo but we're
going to choose not to because we want
to hang out with them and I don't want
to put her in a bad spot and then also I
don't want to feel like she thinks that
I have to pay for her all the time you
know like there's all you know some of
that so I'm like you know thank you for
being considerate that's thank you
Rachel yeah be the considerate friend
but for real and and so for your family
like you know and not that you can make
them do that those kind of things but I
would throw out ideas that are kind of
free or less expensive or whatever it is
that you actually still get time I would
be like listen I'll sign up to clean up
after you guys I'll sign up on Dish Duty
thanks George love it I love it that's
really good and it's only for a season
too Jennifer this is not gonna be your
whole life when are you GNA be out of
debt oh gosh probably two years okay
they're fine when I crunch my numbers
it's gonna take about two years okay and
here's the truth too Jennifer I look
back John delone probably would like
shake his finger and be like that's not
right child psychology Rachel but I'm
like I don't remember being I don't
remember being eight and n
oh yeah for sure not you know what I
mean like your kids are fine they are
fine they really really are they have a
great mom and a great life and no trip
or zoo is going to change that that's
right thank you so much I needed to hear
like you guys you guys like my church PE
are kind of like my family right now so
thank you that means the world add us to
the group chat I know we can't wait to
hear who gets in trouble at that's what
you do add Rachel to the Facebook
Messenger to group chat have her pop in
and just smack some people's five
inexpensive things you can do with kids
under 10 years old just start putting
her blog articles on there that's fun oh
Jif we're cheering you on and remember
it's not forever it is not forever this
is a season of sacrifice to get yourself
in a place where you can go and enjoy
and do the things cuz you actually have
the money to do it so thanks for the
call Jennifer George thanks for the DM
bless to be a blessing yeah that's yeah
just spreading the Lord's work this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsy show we are
happy to be here you guys and if you
love the show whether you're new
listener old listener been with us for a
while if you will share the show with
your friends and family it helps us out
a lot just to spread the word because we
want spread the word we want everyone to
be in control of their money even if you
hate the show and you're here listening
for some weird reason just go ahead and
share it just share it like here it is
yeah cuz at least somebody will see it
they'll think huh that's interesting
maybe spread your hate anden
I know yeah and and even go on uh where
you listen to podcasts and leave us a
review subscribe all those things just
help us out we love it's not for
Rachel's affirmation we promise it just
helps the algorithm show this to more
people that that and we like your
feedback we say that on Smart money
happy hour our podcast we like seeing
what you guys you guys are very vocal
and we like to know that we like to know
what you like what you don't like mostly
what you like but it's fine we can we we
have to we can handle what you don't
like to but yeah just spread and share
the show for us uh always helps us out
thanks so much all right up next we have
Becca in Detroit hey Becca welcome to
the show hi there my question is about
home renovations um specifically how do
we know when it's the right time oh
that's a good question and do you mean
from like a financial standpoint
obviously yes yes from the money
standpoint is this a need or a
want I'd say it's a want um when we
purchased this house it was with the
expectation that we were going to redo
this kitchen because it's just really
ugly it doesn't function too well um
that's a perfectly good reason that
helps me it just helps to know like is
the roof falling off or are the
countertops I so that's a good it just
helps me kind of use a filter here yeah
are you guys um in a financial position
Becca where you don't have debt do you
guys have some
savings yeah so the only debt we have is
our mortgage we have about 200,000 left
on that but no no other debt um and we
have
$125,000 saved up which would be um by
the time the contractors got around to
doing the work the cost of the
renovations plus an emergency fund plus
a little leftover oh my gosh amazing so
you just can cash flow it yeah that's it
that's what makes you think you're not
ready is it just feel like is it a big
number is just scary to spend this much
money does it feel like frivolous
exactly it's a huge huge number it's a
huge number and we're getting it all
over
town so we think it's a real number yeah
I mean if you have multiple bids I mean
Labor's up material I mean it is like
that that it everything is just more
expensive in life long gone to the days
like 10 grand can we'll get a new
kitchen yeah so what is this going to
cost
you we're hearing
$100,000 for all of it are youting are
you moving walls and stuff or is it just
appliances and countertops yeah it would
be a gut it
structural work to support heavier stuff
bigger
islands um and just the labor is really
expensive right now all over
400,000 okay because one thing to think
about is not that everything has to be
about Roi cuz you put a pool in the
backyard it may not Roi and it's okay to
just do things for enjoyment knowing
you're not going to get that money back
out of it look could you being all fun
George I'm such a fdy duddy Rachel
unbelievable but you know with a kitchen
renovation it can and will increase the
value by a certain amount I don't know
that it's going to make a $400,000 house
into a $500,000 house but over time
kitchens and bathrooms those are the big
ones they are the big ones so if there
if there's a place to do it from an Roi
side I think kitchen is the best and
yeah if you guys have it back I mean
this literally this is exactly the
perfect situation to do it and just for
everyone listening remember no debt and
emergency fund they have the cash to
cash flow it and that's it there's no
helck there's no still have our student
loans take a heck to do these
Renovations no and that's what a lot of
people did during Co and so Becca you're
doing it the right way you just got to
do it and what's funny though is like
you said people actually save the money
and they're like oh man do do we really
want to spend it on it but what's great
about doing it with cash to Becca is you
guys well you have your budget and
you're going to stay within the budget
because I'm telling you you go to the
Appliance store and it's like oh we can
get this if you're putting it on credit
you're like just get the nicer one yeah
you yeah you see it and they're like oh
but two levels up oh gosh that's the
really nice one okay when I found out
about levels I was like this is a scam
yeah you don't want the level two tile
Rachel that's basically dangerous for
your family you need the level four tile
I know you can start to if you use debt
you really can start going over budget
because you're like ah we'll worry about
it later but when it's your own money
and you have a strict budget you know
okay nope we're just staying within this
and it helps keep boundaries on this
because home renovations Home Building
all of that can go go off the rails so
quickly so I'm I'm I'm the spender
though Becca so I'm your biggest
cheerleader on this do it and get a
great kitchen we spend so much time our
picture later so we can see it before
and after so I I we're we're giving you
the green light back there that's pretty
rare on this show that you get a
unanimous instant green light but it's
because she's got no debt and has the
cash to do it the two big what she want
stay within that budget it's exciting
that's great all right up next we have
Anthony in Philadelphia hey Anthony
welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me really
appreciate it absolutely how can we help
we're doing great doing
great how can we help you awesome all
right so my question is should I sell
some shares of stock that I have from my
previous employer and my current
employer to put towards existing
debt how much debt do you
have so we have two two pretty big sums
uh not not counting the house we have
14,000 left on a solar
uh and then 38,000 on a car okay and how
much would the stock be worth if you
cash it all out yes so I I can I can
pull out somewhere around
25,000 um I also have about 20,000 right
now sitting in a high yield savings
account how much 20 did you
say yes yeah so so 20 20 of the savings
I could get about 25 from the stock um
my wife and I do have a plan to actually
have the 14,000 paid off of the solar
pretty much in about a month or two we
are going to pull from our savings
account right we're following the kind
of debt snowball method
so yeah that's great um and none of this
is obviously retirement like it's not
tied up in a 401k or rough or anything
yeah it's just stocks you have capital
gains you'll pay when you sell
this oh Anthony's off the line somehow
we lost him Pi up he's back Anthony
sorry we just hung up on you real quick
no it's okay all right so are there
capital gains on these stocks when you
sell you make some money off of it okay
so I would factor that into your
equation make sure you're prepared for
the tax hit on that uh it's not going to
be astronomical I assuming you you
haven't had these stocks super long and
it's not a huge
amount but I would at least calculate
that and make sure that you pay the
taxes on that so but that'll least knock
most of the debt out yeah that's amazing
yeah because we do say to cash shot
everything you have but retirement to
get debt paid off and and we don't like
having too much in Company stock anyways
sing because it's pretty yeah it's
pretty limited and kind of that your all
your eggs are in one basket mentality
which is not ideal with investing
diversification and all that is what we
what we're really going for so um and I
tell you that as a person who actually
did this Anthony so it's not like advice
I tell you to do but I would never do it
I had Apple stock for when I worked at
the retail store back in ' 0809 when it
came time for debt payoff I was looking
around for money and I had a bunch of
Apple stock and so I sold that and it
helped me get out of debt way faster got
me to investing faster got my emergency
fund funded faster and I don't miss
having those stocks and the wh ifs of
like well do you know how much that
would be if you hung on to that that's
what your friends are going to say uh
when you go and sell this so you kind of
have to turn down the noise from all the
opinions and out and inputs and go I
want to be debt free sooner that is my
priority I can always buy more and
invest more later I'm not going to miss
out yeah so Anthony with your savings
and the stock it's about 45,000 and you
guys have about 52,000 in debt is that
right so you'll have 7,000 left to knock
out after all this what's your income
yes household so so my wife is a stay-at
home mom uh she works part-time for our
church and does pull in a little bit uh
so combined we make about 175 oh that's
great dude so we're talking like two
months from now you're dead
free uh theoretically yes but we have
two toddlers and we just had our third
child two months ago so a little bit of
a fear yeah congratulations a little bit
of fear so
so maybe four months we'll give you four
months Anthony it's a great question
though yep cash it out put it towards
the debt and starting with a new little
baby you know what I'm going to send you
Rachel's new kids book I'm glad for what
I have for those Toddlers and the new
baby isn't that sweet that was thanks
George I just thought of it it's a great
gift for the kiddos out there so hang on
the line Anthony we're going to send you
Rachel's new kids book it's a great
[Music]
[Applause]
read
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
bestselling Author George camel we're
taking your calls up next we have Shonda
in Cleveland hey Shonda welcome to the
show hi hi guys hello
hello hi can you hear me yes we can we
can oh okay thanks for calling yeah how
can we
help yes I have money stress I have um
I'm I have an income of like 22
$24,000 but I have two collection
agencies um one is 5,000 which I could
pay um I only have 2,000 more to pay for
that one collection agency and the other
one is
8,000 and I don't know what to do or be
again to pay that
um that debt I don't even know where to
begin I haven't talked to that um
collection agency at all cuz I don't
know what to do cuz I I don't have no
money to pay them and a driveway they
needs to be fixed that's like 20,000
they say so that's an upcoming expense
that's not debt
right yeah that's upcoming what other
debt do you
have um I have student loans that's uh
50,000 a car loan that's
11,000 a home loan that's
75,000 and I was like um one month
behind I think I just caught up and um
let's see um credit card that's 200
$200 dollars of minimum payment or
that's the total yeah no that the total
so I was going to pay them off when I
next time I get paid okay how old old
are
you yeah I'm 53
okay what are you doing for work right
now Nur assistant but I feel like I I'm
overwhelmed I don't know what to do and
I know y'all say don't play the lottery
but that's I've been trying to do that
oh no don't step I know what else in the
convenience store a gas station stay far
away how many hours a week are you
working that's
right um like 40 hours and then
sometimes pick up on my off days okay so
I'm working I'm working and you're doing
what again I'm sorry say it one more
time nursing assistant nursing assistant
but you're only making $24,000 working
as a nursing assistant and working 40
hours a
week yeah okay
okay um yeah I mean I think the the
first thing to be looking at because
what's your degree in because you have
some student
loans yeah um well I went to school for
different
well I really went to school and didn't
really get much of a degree I got okay
one degree and how long you've been
paying on these student
loans for
years and haven't made a and I mean you
know during Co they didn't they wasn't
taking any payments during Co they were
sending your money right back are you
single yes okay well there's some simple
steps you can take that are tactical to
help you but it's going to take
sacrifice it's going to take making more
spending less all of that um so here's
the thing with the collections you've
got to talk to these people we can't
bury a head in the sand and even if you
call them and say listen I can't pay you
I make $10 an hour and I got a lot of
bills and a lot of people who want to
get paid and so I need to keep the
lights on so your one priority is food
utilities shelter transp portation we
call that the four
walls nothing else gets paid before
those get paid I don't care who the debt
is too what the collectors are saying
you got to keep the lights on keep the
mortgage paid so that you don't get
foreclosed on and eat something too and
so beyond that you got to make your
insurance payments we need to keep all
that to protect us and then we can start
tackling the debt but clearly there's
not much to tackle it with because you
have no money left after making minimum
payments right
that's right so I mean so what do I tell
them or what do I do do I write a letter
do I call them i' call everyone you owe
debt to and say listen I want to pay you
but I don't have any money I make $10 an
hour I'm six figures in debt I'll pay
you when I can and what I can but right
now I'm flat
broke okay yeah and then on the income
signs Shonda I mean I honestly I mean I
was you know Walmart Target like these
places are paying up to 20 an hour like
you could double your hourly rates by
working somewhere else I think you're
going to need a different job I just
don't this job is not going to be able
to sustain you and you're working 40
hours so I'm like you're you have a you
know a great work ethic but that energy
is going to something that's not giving
you your rate of return of what you need
right now and so and places like Walmart
Target some other places I mean they
have great benefits like they really do
a great job in helping their employees
so I honestly would be switching
jobs you have to make more you can't be
living on this is there a path for you
to make more in the nursing assistant
world like it's a CNA where you could be
making 40,000 a
year
well I don't know um like the hospitals
or something like that I don't know how
much
they I would do some homework and
research and talk to people who are in
these fields in these positions and ask
them the path and what it's going to
cost and what it's going to take and how
long yeah
yeah agency pays I mean I mean I guess
the
agency but beyond the agency job you
know as a as certified nursing assistant
you should be able to make 30 to 40
versus
22 and with your experience I'd imagine
this wouldn't be a huge leap and so I
would just at least start to do some
homework I know life has got you down
but this is the time the next 10 years
we need to be really getting focused get
the income up get rid of this debt and
have no more pay and sha start binge
watching some of our debt-free screams
um here on the YouTube channel or even
podcast but go through and and and watch
some of these stories because I know it
feels like you're in such a hopeless
situation uh and numbers wise it does
feel hopeless right and and so we want
that some of that to change with your
income and starting to get a grapple on
this debt um but just know that there is
an there is a way out it's just going to
it's going to look different than
probably what you've done in the past
and that's okay but there's people that
do it every day so
continue to to feed your mind with this
stuff if you hold on the line Shonda
Austin's going to pick up and I want to
give you Financial Peace University
that's our nine lesson course on money
just to get you the basics we'll throw
in every dollar premium as well which is
our our budgeting app uh and they have a
great tutorial there when you sign up
there to really walk through and teach
you there here's detailed how you do a
budget uh and Austin go ahead and throw
in Total Money Makeover too and that's
that's Dave Ramsey's bestselling book
and it's the seven baby steps um I just
want to get some some knowledge um of
this plan in you Shonda and I want you
to just like soak all this up because
it's gonna kind of be a different world
that you'll be navigating with money
it's going to look different but I want
you to have
motivation and people behind you
cheering you on and even if it's us on
YouTube cheering you on and and giving
you some encouragement through other
callers or watching their stories I want
that for you cuz I want you to know that
that this can change it's going to be
different it's yeah it's going to be
different from what you've done and it's
gonna be hard none of this is easy none
of this is easy but it is possible I'm
gonna throw even one more thing just
because I feel for Shonda I'm going to
gift you a free coaching session with a
trained ramsy Financial coach who can
walk through all of this with you help
you with the collection side navigate
this wild Journey help you make a plan
with the dead snowball um just because
we can't do that in a radio call and I
really want Shonda to have hope because
I know a lot of older caller there's
older people out there listening who are
in their 50s Rachel and they're going
well I'm In Her Shoes there's no hope
for me and it takes it's harder to do as
you get older it's just harder habits
deeper habits that are you have to break
the mistakes have been compounding for
years the debts been sitting around for
years is in collections so hang on the
line we'll get you connected and give
you a free session with a trained Ramsey
Financial coach yeah um who can help so
that's that's a big part of the problem
is yes and it is Harding hope and
getting a game plan that's right and you
know we talk to to people yeah in their
50s 60s sometimes in their 70s right and
they're they don't have anything for
retirement they're trying to figure this
out and and even though it's a hard Hill
to climb to say okay I'm going to buckle
down I'm going to I'm going to learn
something new change what I've been
doing sacrifice take on that extra job
like all of that is hard but it's also
hard to go into retirement with nothing
if you continue down that path right so
it's one of those things like you choose
your hard yeah and one hard's actually
going to be able to give you money when
you start working a plan and get out of
debt and be able to have some level of
control over your life versus not at all
right so don't give up Shonda you got
this Shonda we believe in you this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day comes from
Isaiah
46:4 even in your old age and gray hairs
I am he I am he who will sustain you I
have made you and I will carry you I
will sustain you and I will rescue you
one man cannot hold another man down in
the ditch without remaining down in the
ditch with him Booker T Washington
that's a that's a good quote right there
that's so true so so true well George
it's been a great it's been a great hour
had we've had some great calls I've
enjoyed it I'm glad you feel the same
way I do I have all right so to to round
out the show let's go to Ethan in
Kalamazoo hey Ethan welcome to the
show hi hi how can we
help um so I just had some questions so
I just turned 18 and I graduated a
couple months ago and I just don't
really have any idea like what to do
with my
money okay so you're 18 years old
graduated from high school what are you
doing now are you in school are you
working uh I'm a pipe fitter and a pipe
buer okay good for you how much are you
making um I make $20 an hour so about
2400 a month okay good for you are you
living at home or are you on your own
yes ma'am you're at home okay awesome
how much money do you
have um right now I have about three
grand saved
up uh in a checking account and then I
have have I think 2500 in a money market
and then I have another 300 something
for
bills okay and do you have any
debt uh no sir great and what's your
question um so I was just like wondering
because I know I feel like every like my
whole life people said like you know
renting like Apartments was like super
bad and stuff and then I heard a couple
times from you guys that you know
renting apartments isn't always the
worst idea and I just figured you know
since I'm young I don't want to get any
in any debt ever you know it scares me
now after I've watched your guys' shows
for 10 hours a day and so I was just
like wondering like what's okay to be in
debt for and like what's not
okay yeah that's a great question well
if you've listened to the show for 10
hours a day you'll know that we are
anti- debt all the way anytime we don't
think there's any such thing is good
debt and the only debt we don't yell at
you for is a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
that you're attempting to to pay off
early so outside of that we don't
believe there's any good debt that it
should be leveraged that it's some kind
of tool we've only seen it cause pain
and harm in the long term and the ones
that brag about it just haven't been
burned yet and so at 18 man if you can
get a hold of those principles now
you're going to be unbelievably wealthy
and you're going to have a great life
yes sir yeah and and the renting thing
Ethan yeah we are not we're not against
renting I mean renting buys people a lot
of patience and gets them in a position
financi then to be able to put a good
down payment on a house uh get out of
debt you know do some things and where a
lot of people feel like it's just
throwing your money away um for us you
know there's there's a level of risk
that you don't have when you don't own a
home because owning a home I mean it can
be expensive I mean you're you know from
roof issues we just had our chimney had
to be completely basically redone in the
inside and so they've been working all
week at our at that um you know we had
stuff with our roof last year St you
know appliances go out I mean it's just
there is so much that you pay for as a
homeowner when you rent you don't have
that expense so there's a there's a
beauty to that right we we eventually
Ethan want you to have a house because
owning a home and real estate being part
of your overall Financial picture is a
great thing and we are all about it but
we want you to do it the right way but
but you're 18 so my question for you is
are you um you know are you going to are
you going to school are you going to do
trade are you going to be doing this job
do you think for the near future are you
happy living at home do you want to be
out on your own where are you at with
just your life stages right now would be
nice to be out on my own but you know
just like the like the apartments in my
area like just a studio those cost about
you know like 1100 to 1300 a month and
that's well over half of my monthly
income right now yeah um I don't really
plan on going to school the place I work
for they do an apprenticeship and so
hopefully I'll start that up uh in
September okay and will that cause a a
raise to
occur yes ma'am that's great what will
you think you'll be
making um uh I'm hoping they'll give me
another dollar so about 21 okay but the
thing is is in you know four or five
years when I'm done with the
apprenticeship and once I become a
journeyman I'm expected to make you know
around 50 an hour yeah that's amazing
they'll be six figures by then
so great Ethan um yeah so what I I
wouldn't be in a rush with the with the
housing situation I mean I think
eventually you'll get to a point um you
know maybe when you're 19 20 and go get
a roommate that's what I had roommates
up until I was married and so get a
two-bedroom and maybe 8 or 9 hundred
bucks a month if you split it and uh go
do that for a while and that will give
you a sense of Independence it'll help
you learn how to be an adult and uh you
know Dave always says that an eagle that
doesn't leave the nest is eventually a
turkey so
it's good I think it's good for your
spirit if you can get out but Ethan I
feel like such a mom right now we're
like he's only been out of you haven't I
mean I guess it'll be coming up on a
year did you graduate last May from high
school um no I graduated early so I
graduated um right before Thanksgiving
nice okay so so you so you've only been
out of school for three months right out
of high school yes ma'am okay so
yeah I just feel like you're just so
young I'm like you don't have to go live
on your own apartment
but if that if he's saying that's
something he wants to do I don't want
people to feel like well once I get out
I need to go buy a house that's right no
no no no no no yeah yeah and if you want
to go and rent an apartment and go do it
that's great that's great but I I do
feel like you've had a lot of Life
shifting and you're learning how to be
an adult right now and if you don't have
to pay for rent right this moment and
you know I think that I think that's a
great thing but I would have plans to
move out right get to your point George
yes while you're at home it brings
dignity I would say every single penny
this is such an amazing season where you
don't have many bills and what happens
and I I Liv this out when I was 18
living at home is I started working and
I just spent every paycheck cuz they
didn't have bills I was like what else
are you going to do I'm 18 let's go have
fun and I just bought gear and stupid
crap and I could have been saving and I
could have been paying off student loans
but I was just being an idiot
just just a little old lad George you
won't be me Ethan you're going to do
great but here's the thing pay cash for
your next car that's where 18year olds
go wrong so what are you driving
now um I have a Ford Ranger is it doing
well for you yeah yeah it's it's been
pretty reliable I've had it for almost
two years now cool so great yep so yeah
I would do what George said just
stockpile some money have a have a date
to say okay you know by I don't care
when it is September or something six
months from now or whatever I'm going to
really seriously look at moving out
being on my own and honestly then by I
think there is something about when you
work and you're not in school you do
feel more like an adult right I mean
like there's a sense you're bringing in
a bunch of money and you're and you're
going to that itch to move out will
probably happen sooner than later I just
don't want you to feel like you have to
rush out right now because you've just
had a lot of life change but um have a
date talk to your parents about it too
and just overc communicate with them
like because you sound like a very
responsible guy you know and so I think
having that plan is great and that money
market account uh is a great place to be
doing your um emergency fund so I would
build it up to three to six months of
expenses which may it will increase when
you move out because you'll have housing
and all of that um but just be putting
money away in that money market account
and um and I think just be saving and
avoid debts and then um be looking at
investing soon after you get that
emergency fund I mean there's some
things you can be doing uh if you hold
on the line Ethan I'm going to give you
George's book Breaking Free from broke
because he does a great job laying out
so many of the myths in our world today
when it comes to money and our culture
and our generation and I think as you
start you know diving into adulthood
more and more you're going to hear more
and more opinions about money and George
does a great job refuting is that the
right word oh yeah great word thanks man
really really pulled that one out
refuting a lot of the the myths and the
lies that people have fallen into it it
will keep you away from debt for the
rest of your life I promise if you read
that book it makes you want to take a
shower when I just lay out the facts and
Ethan's already right there but it's
easy at 18 you start working you feel
like you need to increase your lifestyle
and you start comparing my bud just got
he just got a Camaro you got to just
turn down the noise and all of that and
focus on your goals that's what the kids
want these days Sports really I don't
know why are Camaros the thing I I saw
some nods out there the 18-year-olds
love a Camaro they love muscle car wow
who knew bring I got my finger on the
pulse Rachel man you know what's going
on George you're so so hip well Ethan
thanks for the call and thank you
America for listening thanks to all the
guys in the booth keeping the show float
George thank you you a great co-host as
always
and we'll be
[Music]
[Applause]
back
[Music]
oh